All right, lady, you know that Lee was just shooting his movie in Oklahoma City. And the movie gave him a place to stay because he was there for months. Right. But for two of those weeks, me and the kids came out to join him and the place he was staying in that the movie provided. It was just too small to your whole family. We're a whole family. He went on Airbnb, got us the most beautiful, spacious place to stay. With the nicest host. Well you know if you're planning a trip or you're working
好的，女士，你知道李刚刚在俄克拉荷马城拍电影。剧组给他安排了住处，因为他在那里待了好几个月。没错。但其中有两周，我和孩子们去那里跟他会合，剧组给他安排的那个住处。对我们一整个家庭来说，实在太小了。我们是一大家子人呢。他上了Airbnb，给我们找了一个最美丽、最宽敞的住处。房东也超级好。如果你正在计划旅行或者你在某个地方
somewhere and you want to stay at an Airbnb, I think you guys got to check out their guest favorite because those are the most loved homes on Airbnb. Oh! We were a guest favorite! We were in a guest favorite. You scared me. So sorry, it's true. You're so excited. I was. Well, yeah, I mean, you're actually getting a home other people have stayed in. Yes.
工作，想找个Airbnb住，我觉得你们一定要去看看他们的“爱彼迎精选”（Guest Favorites），因为那是Airbnb上最受欢迎的房屋。哦！我们住的就是“爱彼迎精选”！我们住在一个“爱彼迎精选”里。你吓到我了。非常抱歉，是真的。你太激动了。我是挺激动的。好吧，对，我的意思是，你实际上是住进别人住过的家里。对。
And you know it's been well reviewed. Well, listen, we are huge fans of Airbnb for so many reasons. So for your next adventure, consider Airbnb. Look at us, we're all getting together, jumping on here, and it's our first time seeing each other after our spring break week. Yeah. Yeah.
而且你知道它评价很好。听着，我们是Airbnb的超级粉丝，原因有很多。所以你的下一次冒险，考虑一下Airbnb吧。看看我们，大家聚在一起，连线聊天，这是我们春假过后第一次见面。 yeah。
How's everyone feeling? Does everyone feel like real relaxed? Yeah, I've definitely slept for a week. Did everybody take a break? Yeah. You did? I watched all of the pit. I watched all of White Lotus, all of Righteous Gemstones. I have two episodes left of the pit, so don't say a word.
大家感觉怎么样？大家有没有觉得特别放松？对，我绝对睡了整整一周。大家都休息了吗？休息了。你休息了吗？我把The Pit看完了。我看了所有的《白莲花度假村》，所有的《正义的宝石》。The Pit我还有两集没看，所以谁也别剧透。
OK, I won't. I won't. All right. I have two episodes left of White Lotus, so also please zip it. You're in for a treat. Won't say anything. OK.
好吧，我不说。我不说。好。我《白莲花度假村》还有两集没看，所以也请闭嘴。你接下来有眼福了。什么都不说。好吧。
Yeah, I finished it last night. I just read that it doesn't have the same theme music, the whatever that music is. Each season is different. Yeah. Why? I read, because they had a falling out, the composer. Oh, really? What? Yes. Are you guys spreading the dish? You guys all went on like, like this real like, I'm gonna step away from like social media and I was like, give it to me, I'm home, give me the guss. You're just scrolling through all the stuff. Also you went to a very fancy party, Ange.
对，我昨晚看完了。我刚看到报道说它没有那种主题音乐了，不管那音乐是什么。每一季都不一样。对。为什么？我看到是因为他们闹翻了，那个作曲家。哦，真的吗？什么？对啊。你们这是在八卦吗？你们一个个都说要像这样，像这样真正地“我要远离社交媒体”，结果我一回来就说，快告诉我，我在家呢，把八卦都交出来。你就在那疯狂刷各种消息。还有，安吉，你去了一个非常高级的派对。
Oh. Okay, you guys, I need my- You can tell it's gonna be good if she's downplaying it right from the start. Well, here it is. First of all, I think my license for small talk should be revoked. Why?
哦。好吧，你们，我需要我的——你一听她从一开始就在轻描淡写，就知道这事肯定不简单。好吧，是这样的。首先，我觉得我应该被吊销闲聊执照。为什么？
I don't think I should have small talk. I don't know this story. No, you guys, I'm just, I think I'm out of practice. What did you refer to as being in a candy jar? Oh, Sam. Sam, I as being in a candy jar? Yeah. Oh, Sam. Sam, I wish it was a candy jar. Okay, okay. Well, I didn't go anywhere for spring break.
我觉得我不应该闲聊。我不知道这个故事。不，你们，我只是，我觉得我生疏了。你把什么称为在糖果罐里？哦，山姆。山姆，我把什么称为在糖果罐里？对。哦，山姆。山姆，我希望那是个糖果罐。好吧，好吧。我春假哪里都没去。
I just stayed home and I took just kids to doctor's appointments. Everyone got their teeth cleaned and you know, Isabel and Jack had their wisdom teeth consultations. I did like eight doctor's appointments, I think. I went and got my yearly women's exam. Good, good. Yay, I did it eight doctor's appointments, I think. I went and got my yearly woman's exam. Good, good. Yay, I did it.
我就呆在家，带孩子们去看医生。每个人都洗了牙，你知道的，伊莎贝尔和杰克去做了智齿咨询。我大概预约了八次看医生吧。我去做了年度妇科检查。很好，很好。太棒了，我做到了。我大概预约了八次看医生。我去做了年度妇科检查。很好，很好。太棒了，我做到了。
Okay, so I did all of that kind of like, you know, tending to my garden, if you will. Sorry, that sounded wrong. See, again, take my small talk license, take it away. So I've known Glenn Powell for a long time. Jenna and I met him together years ago at like an award show party. He was so nice.
好吧，所以我做了所有那些，你知道的，修剪我的花园之类的事，如果你懂我的意思。抱歉，这话听起来不对。看吧，再次声明，收回我的闲聊执照吧，收回去。所以，我认识格伦·鲍威尔（Glenn Powell）很久了。珍娜和我多年前在一个颁奖典礼派对上一起认识他的。他超级好。
He's the handsome actor from twisters. Okay. Okay. Correct. And he's also from Texas and we sort of did that like, oh, you're from Texas, I'm from Texas. And we exchanged information and like every once in a while over the years, we'll just check in with
他是《龙卷风》里的那个帅气演员。好吧。好吧。没错。而且他也是德州人，我们当时就那种“哦，你是德州的，我也是德州的”的感觉。我们交换了联系方式，多年来偶尔会互相问候一下，
each other like, Hey, how's it going? Or congrats on this or he'll invite me to something or I'll invite him to something. And he's just such a great guy. So I see online because you know, I'm home scrolling that he has a new line of condiments like condiments made with organic ingredients and it's called Smash Kitchen. Okay. Barbecue sauce, spicy mayo, yes. A whole line of them.
比如，嘿，最近怎么样？或者恭喜这个，或者他会邀请我去参加什么活动，或者我邀请他去。他真的是个很好的人。所以我在网上看到，因为你知道，我在家刷手机，他推出了一款新的调味品系列——用有机原料制作的调味品，叫做Smash Kitchen。好吧。烧烤酱，辣蛋黄酱，没错。一整套调味品。
And I just DM'd him like, hey, this is fantastic, congratulations. And he's like, thanks so much. He's like, are you in town this week? I'm gonna have a little thing to celebrate it. Are you around? And I said, I am. And I'm thinking to myself, oh my gosh,
我只是给他发了私信说，嘿，这太棒了，恭喜啊。然后他说，非常感谢。他说，你这周在城里吗？我要办个小活动庆祝一下。你有空吗？我说，有的。我心想，天哪，
we didn't really do much over spring break. This is going to make Isabelle's day because she is such a big fan. So I text him and I say, I can come. Can I bring my daughter? And he's like, absolutely. That would be amazing because like, you know, his parents are going. This is like, like a family affair. There's going to be wonderful barbecue and lots of good dipping sauces. Anyway, I
我们春假期间其实没怎么出去玩。这会让伊莎贝尔高兴坏的，因为她是他的超级粉丝。所以我给他发信息说，我可以去。我可以带我女儿一起去吗？他说，当然可以。那太棒了，因为，你知道的，他父母也会去。这就像是一个家庭聚会有美味的烧烤和超多好吃的蘸酱。不管怎样，我
tell Isabelle and she loses her mind. And can I tell you guys what I wore? Yes, of course you can say what you wore. Thank you, Sam. I wore a sweater I got at the mall ages ago. Like at a little, you know the little pop-up kiosk in the middle of the mall? Yeah, I couldn't even tell you, like, it was just one of those randos I bought. And then I wore my tennis shorts. Love it. You guys, I wore tennis shorts!
告诉了伊莎贝尔，她简直要高兴疯了。我能跟你们说说我穿了什么吗？可以，当然可以说说你穿了什么。谢谢你，山姆。我穿了一件很久以前在商场买的毛衣。就像在一个小小的，你知道商场中间那种临时快闪摊位买的？对，我甚至说不上来，就是那种我随便买的杂牌。然后我穿了运动短裤。太棒了。你们知道吗，我穿了运动短裤！
That's on brand for you, it's great. I know, but I was like, well, I don't know. You looked adorable, by the way. Thank you. I did my own hair and makeup, and Isabel and I go, she's so tickled. We go really early. We're like the first people there, you guys. It started at seven. We arrived at 708. This is so us now.
这很符合你的风格，挺好的。我知道，但我当时想，嗯，不知道。顺便说一句，你看起来可爱极了。谢谢。我自己弄了头发和妆容，然后我和伊莎贝尔去了，她高兴坏了。我们去得很早。我们简直是第一批到的人，你们。活动七点开始。我们在七点零八分到达。这太符合我们现在的风格了。
I know. And I said, Isabel, we're just going to stay two hours because we wanted to get back home and be able to like hang out and watch movie and stuff. So there's not a lot of people there at that time. I mean, a lot of people there at that time. I mean, a ton of people showed up. Don't get me wrong. I just want to point out, arriving at 7.08 to something at 7 p.m. in Los Angeles is the same as arriving two hours early anywhere else in the country.
我知道。我说，伊莎贝尔，我们只待两个小时，因为我们想回家，还能一起闲逛、看电影什么的。所以那时候人还不是很多。我的意思是，那时候人并不多。我的意思是，一大堆人出现了。别误会我的意思。我只是想指出，在洛杉矶晚上七点钟的活动，七点零八分到达，就相当于在全国其他地方提前两小时到达。
Absolutely. I know. Well, anyway, it was so cute. It was at this fancy, fancy estate with the view of the whole city, like that kind of thing. And there was cornhole, so me and Isabel played cornhole while we waited for people to get there. And then there was like a French fry like stand and with all the different dipping sauces.
绝对的。我知道。好吧，不管怎样，太可爱了。活动在一个非常非常豪华的庄园里，可以俯瞰整个城市的那种。还有玉米洞游戏，所以我和伊莎贝尔一边等别人到一边玩玉米洞。然后还有一个炸薯条摊位，有各种各样的蘸酱。
Jenna, you know how much I love dipping sauces. This was heaven for me. I assume they're his dipping sauces. So we're hanging out. Of course. Yes, well of course. Okay, how many missteps can you make in one conversation? And he was so kind, bless his heart.
珍娜，你知道我有多喜欢蘸酱。这简直是我的天堂。我猜那些是他的蘸酱。所以我们在闲逛。当然。是的，当然。好吧，一次对话里你能犯多少个错误？他真是太好了，上帝保佑他。
So he sees us from across this area, people are around him, and he makes a face like, hey, like that super like, hey, I've seen a friend. I was like, oh, yay. And Isabel's like, Mom, can I please just get one picture with him? I was like, yes, honey, we will make it happen. So we go up and we're chatting with him and he's so nice. Thankfully it was loud, so I don't think he heard me, but I said, congratulations on Smashed Kitchen.
然后他从这片区域的另一头看到我们，周围都是人，他做了一个表情，就像，嘿，那种超级热情地，嘿，我看到朋友了的表情。我就想，哦，耶。伊莎贝尔就说，妈妈，我能跟他合一张影吗？我说，好的，宝贝，我们会实现的。于是我们走过去跟他聊天，他人太好了。谢天谢地当时很吵，所以我觉他没听到我说的，但我说，恭喜你推出 Smash Kitchen。
This is so great. It's Smash Kitchen. Wait, Angela, didn't you do this with the TV show as well with the same name? I did it, the president of NBC, I said congratulations on Smash. Yeah, the TV show. That's now a Broadway musical.
这太棒了。是 Smash Kitchen。等等，安吉拉，你不是也对一个同名的电视剧做过类似的事吗？我做过，对NBC的总裁，我说恭喜 Smash。对，那个电视剧。现在成了一部百老汇音乐剧。
Yeah, so clearly if I can't, it's not in my brain, it's gonna be smashed. I don't think he heard me, so that was good. But Isabel's face, you guys, bless her heart. She literally made this face like, oh my God, mom, seriously. He was like, well, thanks you guys so much for coming out. I said, yeah, we didn't have anything going on.
所以很显然，如果我说不出口，那它就不在我的大脑里，它就会变成 smashed。我觉得他没听到，所以挺好的。但是伊莎贝尔的表情，天哪，上帝保佑她。她当时真的摆出了这种表情，天哪，妈妈，说真的。他说，嗯，非常感谢你们大家能来。我说，是啊，我们也没什么事。
Straight to, great. Yeah. We're gonna miss. And Isabel just looked at me like, what? But anyway, he was lovely and we got a picture and I texted him later and I was like, thanks so much for inviting us out. And he was like, oh, you two cuties, thanks for coming.
直接说到，太棒了。对。我们要错过。伊莎贝尔看着我，一脸：什么？但不管怎样，他很可爱，我们拍了张照片，后来我给他发信息说，非常感谢邀请我们去。他回道，哦，你们两个小可爱，谢谢你们来。
So, Isabel was like, mom, should we stay a little bit later? People are starting to arrive. I'm like, no, no, no, honey. I was like, you don't understand what this valet line is gonna be like to leave this party. It's gonna be horrible. People are gonna be standing out here for an hour to get their car.
所以，伊莎贝尔就说，妈妈，我们要不要再多待一会儿？人们开始陆续来了。我说，不，不，不，宝贝。我说，你根本不懂离开这个派对的代客泊车队伍会有多可怕。会超级糟糕的。人们要在这里站一个小时才能拿到车。
No, no, no. We were the first here. We're gonna be one of the first to leave this party. It's going to be horrible. People are going to be standing out here for an hour to get their car. No, no, no. We were the first here. We're going to be one of the first to leave and we will not be waiting for our car. And then guess who you missed. Well, so we left at 8 45 and we had a lovely time. Leo DiCaprio came. Leo. And you missed him?
不，不，不。我们是第一个来的。我们将是第一批离开这个派对的人。会超级糟糕的。人们要在这里站一个小时才能拿到车。不，不，不。我们是第一个来的。我们将是第一批离开的人，我们才不会排队等车呢。然后猜猜你们错过了谁。好吧，所以我们八点四十五分离开的，我们度过了一段美好的时光。莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥来了。小李子。而你们错过了他？
Leo DiCaprio. Oh, the things you could have, the way you could have put your foot in your mouth to Leonardo DiCaprio. I know, I know. The things I could have, how much could I have gotten wrong? What do you think like you would have said to Leo wrong? Like anything revenant related, the bear? I know this would have been Titanic at best. Yeah, you were great in Titanic-dededed. Yeah, Titanic-ed. Is there anyone else you did or did not say hello to at this fancy party?
莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。哦，你本可以，你本可以在莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥面前说错多少话啊。我知道，我知道。我本可以，我能说错多少东西？你觉得你会对小李说错什么？比如任何和《荒野猎人》有关的，那头熊？我知道，这顶多也就是《泰坦尼克号》。对，你在《泰坦尼克号》里演得真棒。对，泰坦尼克化了。在这个高级派对上，还有谁是你打过招呼或没有打过招呼的？
Oh, I did chat for a while with Lamorne Morris. I love him. Oh, he's great. And while we were chatting, this gal ran up, and by this point, it is like a packed party. And this gal sees us chatting and runs up to us with a little fuzzy microphone. You know how the influencers hold
哦，我确实和拉莫恩·莫里斯（Lamorne Morris）聊了一会儿。我超喜欢他。哦，他超棒的。正当我们聊天时，有个女孩跑了过来，这时候，派对已经挤满人了。这个女孩看到我们在聊天，拿着一个小小的毛茸茸的麦克风跑向我们。你知道网红们怎么拿
the little tiny microphone? And they talk into it? I've never seen that in real life though. I had never seen it in real life either. And she was very nice, but she wanted to interview us about Smash Kitchen. And she asked us if a hot dog is a sandwich, if we think a hot dog is a sandwich.
那个小小的麦克风吗？然后对着它说话？不过我在现实生活中从来没见过那个。我以前在现实生活中也没见过。她人非常好，但她想就 Smash Kitchen 采访我们。她问我们热狗是不是三明治，我们觉得热狗是不是三明治。
I've heard this conversation. This is a hot topic. It is. And I was asked this one time for a newspaper article and people came for me so hard. So I basically was like, LeMorgne don't answer. They're gonna come for you.
我听说过这个对话。这是一个热门话题。确实是。有一次我为一篇报纸文章被问过这个问题，结果大家在网上把我喷得好惨。所以我基本上就说，拉莫恩别回答。他们会来喷你的。
What did you say? What did you answer last time? I said a hot dog is not a sandwich. And by the way, that's what Lamorne said too. And there are people who are like, hey, it is meat and two pieces of bread. It's a sandwich. So is a hamburger a sandwich?
你说了什么？你上次是怎么回答的？我说热狗不是三明治。顺便说一句，拉莫恩也是这么说的。有些人就会说，嘿，它里面是肉，外面有两片面包。这就是三明治。那汉堡包是三明治吗？
That's what Lamorne said. No. And I was like, are like- Lamorne getting too loose with the word sandwich here. You know, is it meat between two pieces? Well, no, because peanut butter and jelly doesn't have meat, but that's a sandwich. Grilled cheese is a sandwich.
拉莫恩就是这么说的。不是。然后我就想，拉莫恩对“三明治”这个词的定义也太宽泛了吧。你知道的，是不是夹在两片面包中间的东西？嗯，不对，因为花生酱果酱三明治没有肉，但那是三明治。烤奶酪三明治是三明治。
I don't think meat is a prerequisite for if something's a sandwich. Meat is not a prerequisite. It's a thing with two pieces of bread. But meatball sub is a sandwich. So what's the difference between a meatball sub and a hot dog? Really? Similar type of bread. Intense.
我不认为肉是某物是否为三明治的必要条件。肉不是必要条件。它就是夹着两片面包的东西。但肉丸潜艇堡是三明治。那肉丸潜艇堡和热狗有什么区别？真的吗？类似的面包类型。太激烈了。
So I guess you're saying that a hot dog is a sandwich. I think I would say that a hot dog is a sandwich. I don't want to get into some weird Star Wars territory. I look forward to this being shared on a lot of site clickbait. Yeah, this is gonna be the clickbait for this episode. Yeah, I will say hot dog is not a sandwich because I've never been to a sandwich store
所以我想你的意思是热狗是三明治。我想我会说热狗是三明治。我可不想陷入某种奇怪的《星球大战》式的争论中。我期待这被分享到很多点击诱饵网站上。对，这将成为这一集的点击诱饵。对，我会说热狗不是三明治，因为我从来没有去过一家三明治店
that sells hot dogs. That's a good, like Subway doesn't sell hot dogs. This is a good, they sell sandwiches. That's a very good observation. And I feel like if I asked for a hot dog at a nice sandwich place, they would say no. They would say, we don't have hot dogs here. Get out of here, sir.
卖热狗的。这是一个很好的观点，比如赛百味不卖热狗。这是一个很好的观察。我觉得如果我去一家不错的三明治店点热狗，他们会说不。他们会说，我们这里没有热狗。滚出去，先生。
They would judge you? Yeah, yeah. Get out of here with your stupid hot dog. Sir, this is a Wendy's, yeah. Yeah, so anyway, that was a big night for us at Spring Break. Huge. But Isabel had the best time and we got the cutest photo with Glenn
他们会评判你？对，对。带着你那愚蠢的热狗滚出去。先生，这里是温迪汉堡，对。对，不管怎样，那是我们春假的一个大日子。超大。但伊莎贝尔玩得很开心，我们和格伦拍了最可爱的照片
and he's just such a nice person. I'm so happy for him. Yeah, but I need my Smalltalk license. I need to go back to Smalltalk license school. I think you just need to avoid the word smash and you're gonna be okay. Anyone else want to share their spring breaks? Please, please don't let me be the only one.
而且他真的是个很好的人。我太为他高兴了。对，但我需要我的闲聊执照。我得回去上闲聊执照学校了。我觉得你只要避开 smash 这个词，你就没问题了。还有谁想分享他们的春假？求求你们，千万别让我成为唯一一个分享的人。
I do want to say when I was driving into the studio today, Billie Jean King was getting her star on the walk of fame. Oh my gosh. Yeah, and I got stopped at the stoplight. I saw a woman giving a speech like right there. So I rolled down my window to be like, who is it? It was Jamie Lee Curtis. Yeah, and I got stopped at the stoplight. I saw a woman giving a speech, like right there. So I rolled down my window to be like, who is it? It was Jamie Lee Curtis.
我确实想说，当我今天开车进工作室的时候，比利·简·金（Billie Jean King）正在好莱坞星光大道上留下她的星星。哦，天哪。对，我在红绿灯前停了下来。我看到一个女人正在发表演讲，就在那里。所以我摇下车窗想看看是谁？那是杰米·李·柯蒂斯（Jamie Lee Curtis）。对，我在红绿灯前停了下来。我看到一个女人正在发表演讲，就在那里。所以我摇下车窗想看看是谁？那是杰米·李·柯蒂斯。
And she was giving Billy a speech that made me be like, I wish she was my friend because she was like, Billy is power, power on the court, power and activism, power and being a friend. And I just felt like I was like at church sitting at this stoplight and it was amazing. It was really cool. What a cool and very,
她正在为比利发表慷慨激昂的演讲，让我感觉：我希望她是我的朋友。因为她说，比利就是力量，球场上的力量，行动主义的力量，作为朋友的力量。我当时感觉自己就像坐在教堂里，坐在红绿灯前，这感觉太棒了。真的太酷了。多酷，而且非常，
this feels like a true Hollywood moment. Absolutely. Like, wow. You roll down your window and it's like Jamie Lee Curtis. Yeah. Wow. Jenna, I have a question for you. I just finished reading the book I was reading
这感觉就像是一个真正的荷里活时刻。绝对的。就像，哇。你摇下车窗，居然是杰米·李·柯蒂斯。哇。珍娜，我有个问题问你。我刚读完我正在读的那本书，
and automatically, I just have a pile of books on my desk that are like up next to my queue. Why am I reading Huckleberry Finn again? Are you reading it right now? Because I'm so sorry because I gave up on it. I bailed on it. Didn't you bail on that, Jenna? Sam, it's because we were going to read Huckleberry Finn and then read this book, James,
然后紧接着，我桌上就堆了一堆接下来准备读的书。我为什么又要读《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》？你现在正在读吗？因为我很抱歉，因为我放弃了。我读不下去了。你不是也放弃了吗，珍娜？山姆，那是因为我们本来要读《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》，然后读这本书《詹姆斯》，
which is a contemporary novel by Percival Everett. This was the book I wanted for Christmas was James. So it's this like retelling of the book, The Adventures of Huckleberry Finn. But that book is told from the perspective of Jim, who is the enslaved black man who accompanies Huck Finn on these quote unquote adventures. And so in the book, James, you're getting to hear everything
这是珀西瓦尔·埃弗雷特（Percival Everett）的一部当代小说。这就是我想要的圣诞礼物——《詹姆斯》。所以它是对《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》这本书的重新演绎。但这本书是从吉姆的角度讲述的，吉姆是那个陪伴哈克·芬恩经历这些所谓的“冒险”的被奴役的黑人。所以在《詹姆斯》这本书里，你可以听到所有
that Jim is thinking and feeling and who he is and his take on their adventure. And it's absolutely amazing. Great. Okay. and feeling and who he is and his take on their adventure. And it's absolutely amazing. Great. Okay. Cool. And so I had a lot of friends tell me that I would appreciate it more
吉姆的想法、感受、他是谁，以及他对他们冒险经历的看法。这绝对是太棒了。太棒了。好吧。感受、他是谁，以及他对他们冒险经历的看法。这绝对是太棒了。太棒了。好吧。酷。所以有很多朋友告诉我，如果我先重读一遍《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》，我会更感激它，
or that it would be a richer experience for me if I reread Huckleberry Finn first. How far did you make it? I mean, where are you at Huckleberry Finn? I made it to their living on the island. Yeah. And Huckleberry Finn has faked his own death and now he's living on the island with James, with Jim.
或者这会给我带来更丰富的体验。你读到哪儿了？我是说，你读到《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》的什么地方了？我读到他们住在岛上。对。然后哈克·费恩假装自己死了，现在他和詹姆斯，也就是吉姆，一起住在岛上。
Okay. So I gave up on Huckleberry Finn. I was like, sorry, Mark Twain. Yeah. This is not what I wanna read on my vacation. And I just started reading James and it's so good. And I am glad that I read a few chapters of Huckleberry Finn just to kind of like remind me John Wickett,
好吧。所以我放弃了《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》。我想，对不起了，马克·吐温。这可不是我想在假期里读的东西。于是我开始读《詹姆斯》，真的太棒了。而且我很高兴我读了《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》的几个章节，只是为了提醒自己约翰·威克，
just to John Wickett. Sure, just to Lord of the Rings it. Have I John Wicked Sam into Huckleberry Finn? Sam was like, why am I reading Huckleberry Finn again? Why have I read three Huckleberry Finn novels back to back, why am I reading Huckleberry Finn again? Why have I read three Huckleberry Finn novels back to back? Why am I reading Mark Twain? I wish I had checked in and I had just finished the book and you're like, oh, I didn't read that at all.
就像“约翰·威克”化一样。当然，就像“指环王”化一样。我把山姆“约翰·威克”化进《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》里了吗？山姆当时说：我为什么又要读《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》？我为什么连续读了三本《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》的小说，我为什么又要读《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》？我为什么连续读了三本《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》的小说？我为什么要在读马克·吐温？我要是早点核对一下就好了，我刚读完这本书，然后你就说，哦，我根本没读那本。
No, no, no. I read a few chapters. Just skip to the thing that you really wanna read. Well, James is great. I really highly recommend it. Well, Jenna, you had a very relaxing spring break. Yeah. What was your takeaway from it?
不，不，不。我读了几章。直接跳到你真正想读的东西不就行了。嗯，《詹姆斯》真的很棒。我真的强烈推荐。好吧，珍娜，你度过了一个非常放松的春假。对。你从中学到了什么？
Do you have a nugget of like something that you reconnected with in yourself? Well, I went to Hawaii for five days with my family, but I took off work the weekend before and the weekend after. So I had like this real separation from my work life for like that whole like nine days where like I truly put an away message on my emails
你有没有什么感悟，比如你在自己身上重新连接了什么？嗯，我和家人去了夏威夷五天，但我把度假前后的周末都请假了。所以我真的和我的工作生活有了一种真正的隔离，大概有整整九天吧，我真的在邮件里设置了自动回复，
and I didn't open them on my trip. I did not do emails on my trip. Wow. I really put it away. And we also had this thing where we wanted to leave our phones in the room all day, me and Lee, because we just wanted to be like super present. Cause you know, Lee just wrapped his movie, but he didn't have to start editing until
而且我在旅行期间没有打开邮件。我在旅行期间没有处理工作邮件。哇。我真的把它隔绝了。而且我们还有一个规定，就是我和李整天都想把手机留在房间里，因为我们只想全身心地投入当下。因为你知道的，李刚刚拍完电影，但他直到
this week. So we could both really put our work away and just be together as a family. And I said, well, the problem is if I have my phone and I'm taking pictures, then I see that I have a text or I see that I have a text or I see that I have a alert. So I like don't even want my phone on me, but I want pictures from this trip. So we went to Walmart
这周才开始剪辑。所以我们俩都可以真正放下工作，好好以家庭为单位聚在一起。我说，好吧，问题是如果我拿着手机拍照，然后我就会看到我有短信，或者我看到我有短信，或者我看到我有提醒。所以我甚至不想随身带着手机，但我又想要这次旅行的照片。所以我们去了沃尔玛，
and we got a little like waterproof digital camera. Cool. And that is what we took all of our pictures on, minus a few pictures on our phone when we got dressed up and we were like, will someone please take a picture of us in front of the sunset. But almost all our pictures are on this thing.
买了一个小小的防水数码相机。酷。我们几乎所有的照片都是用这个拍的，除了少数几张照片——当我们盛装打扮，然后觉得“谁能帮我们在日落前拍张照”时，才用手机拍了几张。但几乎我们所有的照片都在这个相机里。
And we also couldn't really see them. My eyesight wasn't great. If we were swimming or snorkeling, I had no idea if it was even on. I'd have to be like, is it on? Mom can't see without her glasses. Sure. We have the most craptastic photos from this trip.
而且我们其实也看不清它们。我的视力不太好。如果我们在游泳或浮潜，我甚至不知道它有没有开机。我得问：开机了吗？妈妈不戴眼镜看不见。当然。我们这次旅行拍出了最烂透了的照片。
Yeah. They are. Are they blurry? There are photos with like half a finger in front of the lens. We got a couple of those. Perfect, I love it. Eyes are half open, half closed.
是的。它们。是不是很模糊？有些照片镜头前挡了半根手指。我们拍了好几张这样的。完美，我太喜欢了。眼睛半睁半闭。
Like sometimes people are in the frame, but they are so pure. They're like so, like they're better than any pictures we've ever taken on a vacation. I'm now in love with this idea of going on vacation with the craptastic camera. Yeah. And we are in love with these pictures.
就像有时有人在画面里，但它们是如此纯粹。它们就像是，比我们在度假时拍过的任何照片都要好。我现在爱上了这种带着用起来超烂的相机去度假的想法。对。我们都爱惨了这些照片。
They're so fun. But it was just, it was a great vacation. It was like, I really unplugged and I think that it helped change my relationship to my phone. Like I check my phone so much when I don't need to. Yeah, yeah. I always like have to have it near me.
它们太有趣了。但这只是一次很棒的假期。就像，我真的断网了，我觉得这有助于改变我与手机的关系。比如我经常在不需要的时候看手机。对，对。我总是觉得必须把它放在我身边。
I have like, you know, and so I want to keep that going. But then at the same time, I get home and I'm like, well, what if the school nurse calls or what if Lee stops at the grocery store and wants to know if we need a thing? And I'm like, sorry, babe, I just didn't want to look at my phone for three hours. You know, it's like I'm wrestling with like how to bring that home and I don't know how. Lady, lady. What is it? I have an idea for you. You are someone who has a landline.
我总是，你知道的，所以我想保持这种状态。但与此同时，我一回家就想，万一学校护士打电话来怎么办，或者万一李在杂货店停下来想知道我们是否需要买什么东西怎么办？然后我就想，对不起，宝贝，我只是三个小时不想看手机。你知道，就像我在纠缠着如何把那种状态带回家，而我不知道该怎么做。女士，女士。怎么了？我有个主意。你是一个有座机的人。
Oh my God, you're right. The nurse, I need to start giving out my landline. The nurse, the landline, yes. But only give it to people who you would want to call through, right? Like to penetrate your world. So it's the school, it's Lee. Sure.
天哪，你说得对。护士，我得开始把我的座机号给出去了。护士，座机，对。但只能把它给那些你想让他们打进来的人，对吧？就像能穿透你的世界的人。所以是学校，是李。当然。
I mean me. You can have my line, line, line. But don't abuse it, Angela, or Jenna's gonna change your number. I won't abuse it, but I might start prank calling it. Well, I absolutely love that, Jenna. And I can't wait to see your digital photos. I'll be so excited to see them. You know what?
我是说我。你可以打我的座机号。但别滥用它，安吉拉，否则珍娜会换掉你的号码。我不会滥用的，但我可能会开始恶作剧打电话。好吧，我太喜欢这个主意了，珍娜。我迫不及待想看你的数码照片了。我一定会兴奋地看的。你知道吗？
I should post some. I'll post, well, ask my family first. Because there are. Yeah, see which ones. I'll show you for sure in studio. I'll post some from the fancy party I went to in case I never get invited back to one. But we did have a huge life milestone happen
我应该发几张。我先问问我的家人吧。因为有些。对，看看挑哪些。我绝对会在工作室里给你看。我会发几张我去的那个高级派对的照片，万一我以后再也没机会被邀请去那种派对呢。不过我们家今天确实发生了一个巨大的生活里程碑。
in our family today. Huge. Today was the first morning since our kids started school that we did not do carpool drop off because Jack has his driver's license and he's allowed to drive his siblings to school. And there's a parking lot for students that have a driver's license.
巨大。今天是我们孩子上学以来，第一个没有做拼车接送的早晨，因为杰克拿到驾照了，他被允许开车送他的兄弟姐妹去学校。而且学校里有一个专给有驾照的学生停的停车场。
So today was the first morning ever that neither myself or Josh did carpool drop off. Wow. That is such a milestone. I remember talking to this dad and he said that in his opinion, your whole life changes twice when you're raising kids and they're both car related. He said, he was like, the first one is when you can say everyone get in the car and they can just get in it.
所以今天是有史以来第一个早晨，我和乔斯都没有进行拼车接送。哇。这真是一个重要的里程碑。我记得跟一个爸爸聊过，他说在他看来，当你抚养孩子时，你的整个人生会有两次重大改变，而且都和汽车有关。他说，他说，第一次是当你对他们说“大家都上车”时，他们真的自己爬上车。
You don't have to strap them in. And like put on their seatbelt. And the second is when they can drive themselves. Like they're still living in your home, but they can drive themselves. Like they're still living in your home, but they can drive themselves. He's like, there are two car related milestones that like change everything about the dynamic of how you operate.
你不需要把他们绑在座位上。然后帮他们系好安全带。第二次是当他们可以自己开车的时候。就像他们依然住在你家里，但他们可以自己开车了。就像他们依然住在你家里，但他们可以自己开车了。他说，有两个和汽车相关的里程碑，改变了你生活运作方式的整个动态。
And I was, it's like, I didn't know what to do with myself as they walked out the door. I found myself just like yelling random things at them, like, I have extra fruit sticks. And they're like, exactly. Yes. Okay, okay, bye, bye, okay. Like, I know.
我当时，就像是，当他们走出家门时，我不知道自己该做什么了。我发现自己只是冲他们大喊一些随机的话，比如，我有多余的水果条！而他们就会说，好的，好的，再见，再见，好的。就像，我知道。
Yeah, that's a big deal. And then I had all this extra time this morning. I did stretches before my day. Look at you, lady. Maybe, maybe this is the year. You taking the time for you. Maybe this is the year. You're using that extra time for yourself. Maybe this is the year. You're using that extra time for yourself. That's right.
对，这是一件大事。然后今天早上我有了所有这些多余的时间。我今天开始前做了拉伸。瞧瞧你，女士。也许，也许今年就是这样的一年。你开始花时间关爱自己了。也许今年就是这样的一年。你正在把多余的时间留给自己。也许今年就是这样的一年。你正在把多余的时间留给自己。没错。
Maybe this is the year I touch my toes. Who knows? Jenna, I'm going to Coachella this weekend. I think I'm gonna take my phone off, or like leave it in my tent, and just take that film camera you guys got me for Christmas. Oh, yes. Yeah, those photos will trail.
也许今年就是我能摸到脚趾的一年。谁知道呢？珍娜，我这周末要去科切拉音乐节。我想我要把手机关机，或者把它留在帐篷里，只带你们俩送给我的那个圣诞节胶片相机。哦，太棒了。对，那些照片一定会很棒。
So cool. Have fun. Are you gonna see Green Day at Coachella? I am gonna see Green Day at Coachella, yeah. Yay. Nice, very good. Well, this was a fun Friday chit chat. And before we go, I just want us all to say thank you to everyone out there that was part of us
太酷了。玩得开心。你会在科切拉看到绿日乐队（Green Day）吗？我会看到绿日乐队，对的。耶。太棒了，非常好。好吧，这是一次有趣的周五闲聊。在我们离开之前，我只想让我们所有人对外面所有支持我们的人说声谢谢，
getting nominated for a Webby Award. Yeah, thank you. Yes, we're nominated for comedy podcasts. We're in second place right now. That's right, you can vote until April 17th. We're nominated for comedy podcasts. We're in second place right now. That's right. You can vote until April 17th. We're going to put a swipe up in our stories. So we're officially nominated for best comedy podcast where you can go and vote for us.
我们入围了威比奖（Webby Award）。太棒了，谢谢。是的，我们入围了喜剧播客。我们现在排在第二位。没错，你可以投票一直到4月17日。我们入围了喜剧播客。我们现在排在第二位。没错。你可以投票一直到4月17日。我们将在快拍里放一个上滑链接。所以我们正式入围了最佳喜剧播客，大家可以去给我们投票。
Please do. And then we are a honoree for best comedy co-host. And I thank you for the honor. I am honored. It's just a declaration. Yeah, it's a declaration. So there you go. I'll take it. I'll take it. But we love doing this podcast. It means the world to us. So after all these years for people to put us in these categories of best comedy podcast, best co-hosts, I mean what
请大家投票。然后我们还是最佳喜剧联合主持人的荣誉得主。感谢这份荣誉。我感到很荣幸。这只是一个官宣。对，这是一个官宣。所以就这样。我接受了。我接受了。但我们很喜欢做这个播客。这对我们意义重大。所以在经历了这么多年后，人们能把我们归入最佳喜剧播客、最佳联合主持人的类别，我的意思是，这
an amazing thing. So thank you. Yeah, thank you. I'll take it. I like it. Feels good. Feels good. It's a great way to get back on your phone. Yeah.
是一件多么了不起的事。所以谢谢你们。对，谢谢。我接受了。我喜欢。感觉很好。感觉很好。这是重新找回手机的好方法。对。
Yeah, that's a nice message to come home to for sure. All right, you guys. Well, we hope you have a great Friday and we're sending you hugs from over here at Office Ladies 6.0. Yeah. See you later. Bye.
对，回家能看到这样的消息真的很暖心。好了，伙计们。嗯，我们希望你们周五过得愉快，我们从“办公室女士们6.0版”（Office Ladies 6.0）这里给你们送上拥抱。再见。再见。
See you later. Bye. Bye. See you later. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。拜拜。拜拜。再见。拜拜。感谢收听“办公室女士”（Office Ladies）。“办公室女士”是 Audacy 的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制作人是恩斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。Audacy 的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼（Jenna Weiss-Berman）和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯（Leah Reese-Dennis）。“办公室女士”由克里斯·巴西尔（Chris Basil）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。